اهلا بكم من جديد جنوب افريقيا تتعاقد على
شراء خمس مسيرات كبيره الحجم محليه الصنع
لاول مره
[تصفيق]
المسيره التي تنتجها شركه ميلكور الجنوب
افريقيا هي مسيره تكتيكيه تسمى
380 بحسب الشركه فستكون هذه المسيره
منافسا قويا لنظيراتها من المسيرات التي
حتى تقدمها شركات كبرى حول العالم للمزيد
حول هذه المسيره وكذلك المنظومات الاخرى
التي تنتجها شركه مايلكور الجنوب افريقيا
ينضم الينا السيده مارتينوس الرئيس
التنفيذي للشركه بالسعوديه اولا مصر
مارتينيوس اهلا بك معنا في عسكري تاريا
يعني ما الذي يميز مسيره ميلكور 380 جعلكم
تقولون بانها تستطيع منافسه كبرى المسيرات
نظيراتهم النظيراتها في العالم
لقد استثمرت شركتنا كثيرا من اجل تنويع
الخبرات الموجوده في فريق التطوير في
الشركه اذ يتوفر لدينا طيف واسع من
الخبراء
الذين يعملون في مجالات واسعه لا سيما في
حقل التصميم والتطوير وكذلك في مجال
الالكترونيات والاتصالات المتخصصه وقد سمح
ذلك للشركه بزياده توفير انظمه لمنتجاتنا
داخل مصانعنا وهو عامل من شانه بطبيعه
الحال ان يحد من مخاطر الامداد عندما
يتعلق الامر بمتطلبات الصيانه واصلاح
الانظمه وتحديثها
كما اننا حريصون على ان تكون منتجاتنا
متطابقه مع المعايير والجوده العالميه وهو
ما ييسر عمليه الاستخدام والمتطلبات
اللوجستيه الخاصه لدى الجهات المستخدمه
لهذه الانظمه على وجه التحديد
لكن فيما يتعلق بمسيره 380 مصر مرتينوس
انتم لديكم تعاقد مع جيش جنوب افريقيا اين
وصلتم في هذا التعاقد وكذلك هل هناك دول
مهتمه بهذه المسيره اخرى وما هي هذه الدول
لقد توصلنا الى اتفاق مع سلاح الجو في
جنوب افريقيا الذي يقوم بموجب الاتفاق
بتجربه وتقييم الطائره المسيره وفقا
لمتطلباته بغيت تزويدنا بملاحظاته حولها
ويتضمن الاتفاق ايضا بعد حالات الاستخدام
العمليات وصولا الى نشر هذه الطائره
المسيره بشكل كامل ويعود السبب في ذلك الى
اننا نفضل العمل مع مستخدمي منتجاتنا
لنفهم احتياجاتهم على الرغم من توفر فريق
فني مقتدر لدى الشركه بالنسبه لنشاطنا على
الصعيد العالمي لدينا وجود كبير في اكثر
من 70 بلدا يتم تسويق منتجاتنا فيها بفضل
كفاءه قسم التسويق في الشركه ولقد اجرينا
قدرا كبيرا من النقاشات رفيعه المستوى
لاسيما بشان الطائره المسيره 380
نحن متفائلون جدا حيال المبيعات
المستقبليه لهذه المسيره
مستر مارتينوس فيما يتعلق بقيود التصدير
هل هناك اي قيود معينه للتصدير تفرضها
عليكم الحكومه في جنوب افريقيا لتصدير هذه
المسيره سواء لدول في الشرق الاوسط او حتى
على مستوى العالم
الجواب هو كلا لان منطقه الشرق الاوسط
كانت تاريخيا زبولا مهما لصناعه الدفاع في
جنوب افريقيا ولم نواجه على مدى السنين
قيودا او عراقيل كبرى بشان هذا النوع من
الصادرات كما تربط حكومات بلداننا علاقات
جيده والدليل على ذلك عدد مشاركات حكومه
جنوب افريقيا في القمم التي عقدت بين
الجانبين
من جهه شركتنا نحن نبذل ايضا جهودا في
مجال توطين صناعه الدفاع في البلد الذي
ننشط فيه الامر الذي يجعل المتطلبات
اللوجستيه والصادرات اكثر كفاءه
لديكم الان ثلاث مكاتب في ثلاث دول
السعوديه وكذلك الامارات وايضا في الهند
كيف عزز وجود مثل هذه المكاتب من مكانتكم
الدوليه كشركه عامله في الصناعات الدفاعيه
وكذلك هل لديكم خطه للتوسع اكثر في
المستقبل ام لا
لقد كان لمكاتبنا الدوليه بشكل عام تاثير
ايجابي على الشركه لاننا نرى انفسنا شركه
عالميه تقدم حلول الدفاع وقد سمح لنا فتح
هذه المكاتب بالعمل مباشره مع مستخدمي
منتجاتنا في كل بلد علاوه على الاستفاده
من العلاقات التي تربط البلد الذي نوجد
فيه بالبلدان المجاوره
الوفاء السوق بالنسبه لنا واسعه وتسمح لنا
باخذ البلدان التي لديها الرغبه في
التعاون مع شركات عالميه مثل شركهنا في
الحسبان
واستطيع ان اعطيك مثالا جيدا على ذلك
فاختيارنا للوجود في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه يعود للتعاون والدعم الذي وفرته
الحكومه السعوديه
للجهات الفاعله العالميه من اجل الاستثمار
في السوق المحليه
والمساعده في تنميه قدرات السعوديه في
مجال الدفاع وهذا التوجه يتماشى تماما مع
سياسه ورؤيه شركتنا السعيه الى التوسع
مصر فيما يتعلق بقيود التصدير هل هناك اي
قيود تصدير معينه تفرضها عليكم الحكومه في
جنوب افريقيا سواء فيما يتعلق بمسيره
ميلكون 380 او حتى غيرها من المنتجات التي
تقدمونها في الشركه سواء لدول في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط او حتى لبقيه الدول على
مستوى العالم
ان القاره الافريقيه قاره ناميه الى حد
كبير ولديها الكثير من الامكانات التي لم
تسخر في السابق والصناعه في افريقيا تغيرت
بشكل عام انا شخصيا اكثر ارتباطا بمنطقه
الشرق الاوسط لكننا قمنا بدور كبير في
تطوير منتجات في اسواق افريقيا المحليه
بالاعتماد على المهارات المحليه
مثل مارتينوس الحرب في اوكرانيا انعكست
بشكل كبير على الشركات العامله في مجال
الصناعات الدفاعيه وكان لها اثر سواء في
الخطط الانتاج المتعلقه بالوقت الحالي او
حتى في المستقبل كيف يعني اثرت هذه الحرب
على خططكم سواء الحاليه او المستقبليه في
مساله الانتاج
بالنسبه لتاثير الحرب علينا كشركه مصنعه
نحن على علم ببعض الملاحظات التي صدرت حول
هذا الصراع ويمكن ان اشير في الصدد الى
مساله الموثوقيه والدعم الخاصه بالمنتجات
خلال تنفيذ العمليات وهو ما دفعنا الى
اعداد بعض التصميمات من اجل تعظيم هذه
القدرات الى جانب تطبيق تكنولوجيات جديده
من اجل معالجه اوجه القصور التي ظهرت خلال
تنفيذ العمليات
مصر مارتينوس دوبيرا الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركه ميلكور الجنوب افريقيا بالسعوديه
شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا